Oh my
gosh, it scared me.
Why is it so loud?
Wait, hold on.
I didn't have it in with headphones on.
Oh my gosh.
Hello, everybody.
One second.
Hold on.
I'm going to...
Maybe it's right.
This is 75.
For anybody who's like...
I didn't actually could hear it.
So I was like, I didn't realize it was so loud.
Spook to me.
I thought this was not supposed to be a scary game.
I thought it wasn't supposed to be a scary game.
Wow!
Thank you for all the gifts!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, everybody.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Happy Oji Day!
Thank you!
This game is so PN, chat chat, and no spoilers.
I know everybody in the chat has been like, prepare your tissues.
Well, I have a tissue box.
have a good oh see you there thank you did you guys know that today well i guess not anymore in japan but um november 4th you'll be seeing a lot of good blank days this month because uh because in japanese you can read you can read like one one like november as e like good you know you know e in japanese and then and then you know with like a kotoba sobi like a wordplay they'll and like different days will kind of like mean other things so you'll see a lot of like good blank days probably this month so that's your new hollywood lesson thank you so much where's the thank you thank you thank you thank you Oh my goodness,
thank you so much.
I can't control, thank you so much for the pink!
Thank you!
Thank you for being a cute, silly idol.
So today is 11.4 is E- Oshi Nohi.
So a lot of people have been posting things about their- their, uh, Oshi and stuff like that.
You'll always see like artists participate in stuff like this like it'll be like I'm trying to think of another example Oh my gosh, thank you bro.
Whoa, I closed my eyes for like two seconds Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh the chat became so colorful Oh Kuparia happy birthday.
I hope I said your name right.
Happy happy birthday.
Oh my gosh Kara!
I love seeing your performance at USIF!
Ah!
What the heck?
Don't send me that.
Thank you.
Emily Locke, thank you for the Hawkeye Super!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much for the Hawkeye Super!
It's a good Oshita that I'm glad I was able to be here today!
Thank you!
Ah, so, you know.
Even if it's not still the 4th in your time zone, don't forget to say something nice to your Oshis, maybe a little bit, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
But thank you guys for all the nice messages!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm trying to think of another example.
Something nice!
Why can't I think of anything?
I don't know.
I can't think of anything.
Hold on, I'm gonna look it up.
Pocky Day is on the 11th.
That is so true.
That day is the Pocky Day.
That is Pocky Day.
Happy Oshy Day.
Thank you.
I'm honored to be your Oshy if I am.
E...
Maru Maru?
Maru Maru nohi?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what do you mean?
I'm like looking on some...
Oh, this is like some person's blog or something.
Is there a nice white pun today?
There is.
Like there's like...
Thank you!
That's my kamioshi, Deleran!
Why doesn't this list anything though?
So good good opie, good opie, good tummy.
Good meat.
Hearing you say you're honored to be by Oshi, maybe blush for some reason.
I love.
Wow.
So yeah, it's always fun because on Twitter you'll get like all the artists who will post stuff on those days.
So it's fun.
Happy Yoshi Day.
Happy Yoshi Day everybody.
Thank you so much.
I have a lot of Yoshi but Minto is my Kamiyoshi.
Thank you!
But today we're playing a game.
I think this game is a little longer too, so I would like to beat it today.
I don't want to probably put it in two parts.
To the moon!
I've never played this game before.
I've seen other VTubers play it, but I've never like watched it.
So I'm going in basically completely blind.
It's my birthday!
Memory of my youth.
Just a moment's silence.
Monarch, happy birthday.
A moment's silence?
My advice for today, watch Min Van Tove and use code boomer on gamer subs.
See, see, thank you.
So I guess we could just begin then.
Wait, I kind of want some mood lighting for this.
decided I wanted it.
I decided I want mood lighting.
Whoa!
Even with the moon shining on me.
Jay!
Thank you!
Tomorrow's my birthday!
So many birthdays!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday, Jay!
Thank you!
Thank you for the pink!
Did you guys know that today is a super moon?
So...
Actually, it's so fitting.
It's the super moon.
The moon has been so bright lately.
So, to the moon!
To the moon we go!
It's peak timing.
Do I need to play- Can I play this with Mouse?
Or do I need a controller?
Oh!
Mouse works bust?
Okay, okay.
And let me know how the audio is and everything too, so...
Point and click.
Oh, okay, okay.
Aww.
Happy Yoshi Day.
Whoa!
That doesn't sound good.
Oh, my God.
The heck was that in the...
Is that a squirrel?
Yeah, I see.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Where were you looking, Neil?
Well, excuse me for heroically evading that squail coming out of nowhere.
No way.
You ran over it!
Death.
Death's penalty.
Excuse me, princess.
Oh, my god.
Oh, you ran over it anyway.
You ran over it and hit a tree.
There was something, like, kind of weird looking, that scammer.
off up in the corner though look don't worry it's a company car I think that's even worse are you kidding me the boss is going to kill us hmm we'll just say I was saving a puppy oh my gosh and happy birthday he likes puppies right he's more of a cat person why does the world have to be so complicated Fine.
Whatever furball he fancies.
Crisis averted.
Good.
Go write that on your report later.
Let's grab the equipment from the car and move already.
Oh.
Oh, I thought the squirrel was part of the...
Can I take the squirrel?
Tisk, tisk.
Oh, come on.
I crashed the car while trying to evade it.
What more do you want?
Not crashed the car and evade it?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
That's asking too much.
What was over?
What is this?
Oh my gosh.
Wild's household ahead.
Putting up a sign where they live in the middle of nowhere is like asking to be robbed.
We move so fast.
What the heck is that?
Hey, the equipment's still in the car.
Oh, my bad.
Received equipment?
Got this sucker.
Let's roll.
Oh, but what's... Oh, wait, we can go either way.
Let's go this way.
The sign to the house points the other way.
Oh, how kind of it to exist.
Oh, now we're thinking that is a nice thing to have.
Maddie, thank you!
Hey, wait, don't forget the car.
Just wanted to see if you'd remember.
Oh, there we go.
How thoughtful of you.
Look at that bird.
It's been a long time since I've played like an RPG maker game, you know?
What?
What's with these trees?
Why are they bald?
Sorry guys, I tried.
Okay, I'm not gonna explore so much.
We don't need to.
Wait, what did I...
What the heck was that?
Oh my gosh, I can pet the bird!
Pokemon!
boulder here maybe it's their security system cucumbers we don't have time for this fluff let's try pushing it out of the way where's your whimsy yeah strength hm please maybe we could find a tree branch to jack it with wait or we could just call it a night and blame it on that no i'm not gonna go home i think we could Push it by hand.
Alright.
On three.
One, two, three!
What?
I don't even...
Which was that?
Wait, why did it...
Not a boulder.
That's for sure.
Oh my gosh, imagine if they left.
We need to get going for now.
We'll figure that thing out later.
Right.
Why was it squishy?
Oh, oh, those were like some more squirrels or something.
I'm just going along the pathway.
Oh, I guess I should be looking around and seeing if I can click on anything.
Sounds so pretty.
I want to go to the beach.
I don't want to live in a lighthouse, though.
There's too many...
Lighthouses are too cramped for ghosts.
There's so many other ghosts in there.
Oh, I thought he was talking to her.
I was about to be like, that's another child.
All colors.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Good to see you.
What about crab ghosts?
What about them?
Fish slander, how?
I'm saying for a ghost, it's very crowded.
If you're a normal person, maybe if you don't have a strong sixth sense, you'd be fine.
Not a bad place to retire at, huh?
I could do better.
This guy.
Night shifts, love them or hate them.
You know the answer, you stupid owl.
Dang.
Mr. Owl.
It's probably gonna be another all-nighter, you know.
I know.
And I doubt they'd have any coffee.
Why wouldn't they have coffee?
Shut up.
And the ocean waves will sing lullabies.
Not through your blathering, they won't.
Sky.
Man, thank you so much.
Happy Kamiyoshi Day.
Me, no word smart.
Thank you.
Don't forget the equipment, moron.
I don't get paid enough for this.
This guy is making me sleepy.
Act 1.
I never told anyone, but I always thought they were lighthouses.
They might be.
What else could they be?
Dr. Watts and Dr. Rosaline, I presume?
Thanks for coming on such a short notice.
What if they're trying to exercise this place?
That's okay.
I tend to be bad at predicting deaths as well.
Oh, wait, somebody did die!
Are you the patient's daughter?
Oh, no, I'm just his caretaker.
and these are my children Sarah and Tommy they just run around because they're crazy someone's dead and they're just they're just going nuts so in the house it's not exactly a nine to five job so Johnny lets us live here Johnny I suppose this Johnny is our man Johnny's dead Johnny listen if it's a kid we're dealing with I don't think we're the ones you want no no he just prefers to be called that he's a young at heart he's upstairs right now with his medical doctor Johnny come with me wait he's still alive or what's going on I'm scared I don't want to see a dead body come on grab that case and let's go when my back breaks one day I'll sue you with the insurance claim this is so out of pocket it.
Grab it.
Receive the equipment.
Alright.
Let's head upstairs before I drop this.
Go upstairs.
Wait, can I go other places?
Like here?
The patient is waiting upstairs.
Better not waste time.
Okay, okay.
We're going.
I'm observing.
I'm pointing and clicking.
Oh!
It's...
Bones o'clock.
Wait, what is this?
I could take it.
I could steal.
Four River.
By Johnny.
What kind of a song is this?
It's just two notes repeated over and over.
What is it?
Oh, no, not the whole time.
Oh, I guess a little bit.
Four River.
Let's go upstairs then.
Oh my gosh I'm not a huge fan of the walking It's kind of awkward Okay they're gone Whoever gets there first gets to play the melody
No fair you pushed me Did not Whatever you get the boring two notes anyway
Those kids are pretty good for their age Hey You're the one who said there was no time to waste.
And incidentally, I'm the one who is carrying the weight of a small meteoroid.
Yeah, yeah, come on.
Oh my god.
The music stopped.
Hello?
Ready to set up?
Look around first.
Gee, you know, I think I'd like to carry this excruciatingly heavy object around some more.
Thanks for asking me, though.
Johnny?
Selection of readings for medical journals.
I don't think there's really...
Oh wait, can I go through here?
Oh, bye!
What's that?
There's something shiny down here.
Oh, the light.
Oh, he won't be needing that anymore.
Let's see what we got here.
It won't...
Why can't I click on it?
Like, it says I can click on it, but when I click on it, nothing happens.
Pretty sure you don't have to use the mouse to move.
I'm not!
I am sometimes clicking, but I'm using arrow keys.
He's unresponsive at this point, but by the looks of things, he's still consciously hanging on.
It's hard to say how long you'll have, but I would hurry.
Ready to set up?
Okay.
Yes.
It'll just be a moment.
What are we setting up?
Are we transferring his consciousness into the machine?
We're making him a robot body.
Are you sure a common household power outlet is sufficient?
No worries.
We're the experts.
Putting him into the metaverse, so...
Oh crap.
Pirate, thank you!
What do you mean you don't know if it counts?
Of course it counts.
Standard procedures, just keeping you on your toes.
Whoa, whoa!
We are putting him in the metaverse!
Metaverse?
No!
This world is...
How's he doing?
Not so well.
If I were to say he's got just a day or two left.
That's plenty of time.
The Mintoverse.
So you two can grant him any wish, huh?
To try at least.
But we always succeed because we're awesome.
Awesome, awesome.
So what's the wish?
The moon.
Oh my gosh.
What's that guy in the minions movie?
Oh my god, Gru!
Yeah!
It's Gru!
The moon?
Gru, aka Johnny.
The moon.
He wants to go to the moon.
The geysers just keep on getting crazier, huh?
So can you do it?
It depends.
She meant to say yes.
Why don't you tell us about our client here?
That I don't really know much.
Johnny's an odd man.
Through the two years that I've worked here, he rarely spoke.
He worked as a craftsman for most of his life.
and his wife passed away two years ago.
Aww.
Moon.
I don't really know many details.
I would have known more if I were his paper boy for Pete's sake.
Shush, just do your thing.
Dr. Watts is this guy.
Well, I suppose if you look around the house, he may find some more info.
I suppose Johnny wouldn't mind since he signed for you two.
Hmm, so be it.
Alright, which one of us plays Detective?
I want to be Dr. Rosaline.
Dr. Watts is a weirdo.
Thanks for the offer, but I'm busy leaving a butt print on this chair.
Right, do continue.
Tommy and Sarah can show you around.
They're probably at the piano downstairs.
Alright.
Okay, let's try these again.
at them okay doctor he is unresponsive yeah consciously hanging on okay
wait come back here for a moment I have something for you yes oh yes yes here take this it's dangerous to go alone remote pinch patient monitor that'll keep you updated on johnny's status thanks i was just going to ask for it johnny's heart monitor is now activated in men that's kind of freaky what i'm always gonna know if johnny's alive uh burn out thank you so much for that donnie captain thank you
oh this is it oh my gosh legally blinds i'm sorry if this has spelling errors what the heck no why would you apologize Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Let's talk to the children.
What you want?
No, I keep playing.
I quit bothering.
Wow.
Just the beef.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Candy can!
Uh, turn the light on.
It's got some garbage.
Okay, not much else going on in the kitchen.
The beef.
Oh, sometimes the perspective is not so great.
You guys know I have...
Oh, I better ask those kids first.
Oh, we'll go over here.
I'm turning on...
I'm wasting their electricity bill like crazy right now.
Turn on and store tap water.
Sure.
I don't know why we need to do that, but who knows?
Look at these loaves of bread!
And they go downstairs?
No.
Okay, children, children!
Show me around the house, children!
Sarah and Tommy, right?
Your mother said to ask you two to show me around the house.
Okay.
Maybe we will.
Maybe.
I think we just need to look little convincing that's all what do you think Tommy little water in my pockets just for later something I might want to suck a line you know yeah what would you like we want one trillion oh my god they really are Gru's kid huh one trillion dollars or the candy can mom hides from us yeah or that huh there's a giant candy can top of the high shelf that we can't reach it's in the kitchen mom puts it in there to save for when we do chores what did they get a lick each time they do chores or something mom let's just have a little lick of a candy can as a treat get it for us and we'll give you a tour through the house what do you say well sure i'll get it for you my mother used to keep candies on high shelf too i'll go get it they're sharing it like a salt lake imagine it's like you get it it's covered in dust and ants like the kitchen door is right next to the stairs now go
why doesn't minto let us lick a candy can there's that candy can oh not even we can grab it how tall is the mom
Received candy can.
There we go.
Okay.
Terrible calories.
Wait, no, no.
I'm not trying to go that way.
Okay, there we go.
Too short.
Just like...
Just for...
Like for real.
Okay, I got what you wanted.
Good old.
Candy cane.png candy cane.
If you come and give me a tour of this instant, I won't sneeze on it.
The side eye.
They were like, what did you just say?
What did you just say?
Where do we start?
I know.
There's this funny room in the basement.
I don't like that funny room.
What do you mean by funny room?
You'll see.
It's weird.
Oh, is Johnny a little freaky?
It's the cannibalism room.
We need to get the keys, though.
The old man hid it inside a book in the study.
What's the study?
Is this the study?
This is the book room.
Definitely the dungeon.
Oh, my God.
Johnny's freaky.
Happy coming, Oshite.
Thank you.
The key to the funny room is in the thickest book on the upper shelf.
I want to read his diary.
Tommy used to throw books at me and call it a book fight.
Until one day I threw one back and he needed a band-aid.
Just a bunch of books in here.
They've nothing I don't know.
They've nothing I don't know about, though.
Okay.
Tommy
The emperor's new clothes Oh that's the one where the guy's like actually naked What's the accent we're going for with this family I don't know Dusk light The tale of a girl who fell in love with a zombie Who emitted the smell of daisies When showered with gentle sunlight Oh my gosh wait it's twilight Oh Oh my god!
I want to read.
Uh, maybe another year.
What?
He chose its hiding spot well.
Wait, that's so messed up!
No, please!
We could still read the emperor's new clothes.
And the colors!
The colors of that beautiful fabric!
I have never seen anything like it in my life!
They all tried to conceal their disappointment at not being able to see the clothes.
A child, however, who had no important role and could only see things as the eyes showed them to him went up to the carriage but he hasn't got anything on the child says don't talk nonsense his father reprimanded with the boy's remark which has been heard by the bystanders was repeated over and over such a silly story oh my eyes turn it off turn it off Wait,
if I turn it on...
Okay, no, it doesn't make it so that I can, like, read it.
We can open the funny room in the basement now!
Okay.
This is the basement.
We play hide and seek in here.
Turn on the light before you trip over something.
Is this kid, like, got a...
Like a...
What's the word?
Southern accent?
Before you trip over something.
is locked uh
oh oh no no that's not what i meant to do please okay the perspective is my downfall it's my greatest it will bring me to ruin the cabinet is filled with unused fine china boxes filled with colored papers chest is locked okay oh my gosh i just Let's get close to the stairs and it brings me up.
I think it might be better for me to point and click to move than use the arrow keys.
Dusty pile of anamorphs books.
Okay, Johnny, I was not familiar with your game.
Open door with the room key.
It's like a cave in here.
This isn't a...
A horror game?
A broken music box.
A stuffed toy platypus.
It looks adorable enough to annoy Neil.
Might come in handy.
Poke it.
Oh!
Wait, what just happened?
Set it up?
If we take anything, is he gonna...
Well, the guy is dying.
I guess he wouldn't know.
But can I...
Maybe I have to take it.
I can't...
out of paper why scary received toy platypus we're just stealing now okay this is freaky who doesn't have a freaky origami rabbit collection it is did you see it what do you two know about all those rabbit nothing the old man didn't want anyone to go inside so we never told him there are more of them actually where inside the abandoned lighthouse just beneath this cliff want to go see I got the keys you aren't supposed to go in there either are you remind me to never take you to Neil's house who the heck is Neil you Want to go see the lighthouse?
Well, it's rather cold outside, but...
Yeah, go see the lighthouse.
You know what?
Fine.
Maybe it'll tell me more about those rabbits.
Let's go check out that old lighthouse out.
Her partner.
Oh, it's Wads.
It's Dr. Wads.
Neil Wads.
Why is the music so scary all of a sudden?
Whoa, whoa, gosh.
We go outside.
zooming.
Meow, meow.
Wait, how do I get there?
There it is!
We need to head south to the street and take the other path to get down to it though.
Yeah, I forgot my parachute.
We're zooming, we're zooming.
And you'll see Sierra go, so true.
Wait, we have to go all the way back to the street?
Sorry, I'm constantly adjusting the music volume.
So if it gets a little loud, just let me know.
Or anything.
Oh.
It's here!
Huh?
My novelty beach ball!
I thought I lost it.
Ah.
It's stupid anyway.
Oh, I'll never lose it again!
I'm gonna hide it.
Don't look.
Oh.
Okay, done.
Okay, let's just hurry to that lighthouse.
It's smoking.
Who's the dummy that crashed the car?
Why does he talk?
I can't get over Tommy's accent.
Not me.
it's pretty dark out aren't you kids scared of course not we role play it anyway what does that mean the minke what Tommy is a super powerful knight and I'm a mighty magician yeah we destroy all evil oh that's uh that's nice do you roleplay too I uh No Oh come on Dr. Rosaline She's not cool enough to do it Hey I could if I wanted to Yes but differently Yeah Something that the children should be participating in
I love meant to the moon and back Stop it Just you children watch Yeah Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I think I'm gonna be struggling with these, with the, with the walking this entire time.
A squirrel!
Wait, did she just call it a squirrel?
Just like me?
Oh no, it's a terrible squirrel gone.
What the heck is...
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
Don't worry children, I'll protect you!
What?
Even they're confused.
Oh my gosh!
Attack.
With a shoe.
Yelling volume loudest.
Your time is at an end.
Squirrel gone.
Yeah, stop it!
We tell Ma you, animal abuse.
I think these kids have southern accents.
Yeah.
She'll call the cops on you.
What?
I was just...
I wasn't gonna...
Didn't you say you liked roleplay?
Did I mess up the battle?
You should have been ashamed of yourself.
Why did these kids, like, regress?
to caveman speak.
Sometimes they talk so properly and then they become this.
Let's name it Teddy.
Let's just forget this happened.
What did just happen?
I would like an explanation, please.
I would like some sort of...
like some sort of reason why that occurred.
Oh, abandon...
Gosh, there's probably so many ghosts in there.
What is this?
In memory of River E.
Wiles.
Wait, the song was called For River.
River Wiles.
Was she John's wife?
I don't know.
Come on, the lighthouse is right there!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, That one's special though.
This is it!
Seems like this hasn't been lit in years.
A multicolored paper rabbit.
Hey, this wasn't here when we came last week.
Oh yeah, Johnny must have came here before he fell ill again.
This is the only one with two colors, huh?
You know, these things actually look pretty hard to fold.
Kind of an odd hobby, though.
Oh, that's my phone.
It's Watts.
Is everything ready?
All right.
I'll be right there.
Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing.
Where is ringtone?
Why do you have a creepy ringtone?
the monsters away.
Come on, let's head back.
Received paper rabbit.
Are we just taking it?
Okay.
We stole.
We keep stealing.
We can't stop stealing.
What the heck?
They put a melon on his head.
Oh, why don't you be late by another half an hour?
Not like we got a dying client or anything.
Dorgo, thank you!
Good job.
Did that work?
Ah, thank you for the 50 years.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
It's not a melon.
It's a science melon.
I got caught up in something.
I got caught up in something, too.
It's called our job.
Get off your high horse.
I'm late.
Just this one time and you milk it.
Jed, no, thank you.
At least tell me we're good to go.
Of course we are.
because I'm competent.
Oh my gosh.
Your helmet's on the couch.
Chop, chop.
Oh, here.
Initiate?
Wait, not yet.
What's going on?
Okay.
What do you have to say?
Go on.
I'll watch over his physical conditions through the procedure.
By the way, I'm curious.
How does it work?
Do you just write him another life Like a novel?
No, we can't just make up new memories out of thin air.
Then, how do you do it?
Not us.
The machine does most of it.
Oh my gosh, the chat is like all so and so getting gifted.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Naturally, since we aren't paid enough to get our hands dirty, in a nutshell, we simply travel through his memories to as early as possible.
When we do, transfer his registered desire of going to the moon to the reconstruction of the world and himself with the early state and with the help of a wiki of data in his own the machine would then simulate a rerun except this time he'll have the motivation of his of his registered desire with him all his life so you'd be depending on him fulfilling his own wish by simply having the desire to how could that be?
Everyone has ambition for things, but most don't accomplish them.
That's because in the real world, ambitions fluctuate and fade.
People start things with a passion, but eventually they lose that initial drive and slow down.
But imagine if you locked onto that initial push through your entire life, never wavering.
It's more powerful than it seems.
That being said, no ambition is better go get started oh of course sorry freaky it's kind of freaky they like use your old memories to like push this false idea on you paperback thank you
it's in it's it's kind of strange
All right, here we go.
Hello, I am Dr. Rosaline, and I'm going to take you to the moon, little child.
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, this should be the last accessible memory.
Whoa.
Disable speech for all except Johnny.
Done.
Let's get him.
Oh, I get to see you.
Oh, this is kind of weird, though.
My mouse has to go to, like, the top of my screen.
I hope that doesn't make it weird later.
Oh, whoops.
Johnny.
Are you downstairs?
No.
Johnny?
Happy Oshida Mickey!
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday!
Happy Oshida!
I was on autopilot.
Thank you!
Ward and happy birthday.
Johnny?
Oh.
Johnny's old man.
What a pleasant surprise.
We don't get many visitors around here.
My name is Dr. Eva Rosaline.
And this is Dr. Von Matterhorn.
Dr. Lorenzo Von Matterhorn.
Is Papa?
Eating candy?
No, Papa.
Then open your mouth.
Eating candy cane?
Dr. Neil Watts.
Are you familiar with the Sikman Agency of Life Generation?
Oh, are you two from the agency?
How convenient.
I've just been thinking of calling you.
Lily, get us some tea, please.
Lily?
Actually, you've already called us.
Wait, this is so messed up!
So he's gonna know?
Oh!
We're here to fulfill our contract from the relative future.
Careful there.
If you slip off the cliff, we're gonna have to reload this memory.
Watch it, Neil.
Show some respect.
It's just a program, you know.
I know, but this is his last accessible memory and we need its cooperation.
First comes to worst, we can just reboot it.
Why would you waste time like that?
You...
Me?
Oh, Naga.
You are here to take me to the moon, aren't you?
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Yes, John.
Johnny.
Call me Johnny.
I suppose I had a good run.
Not good enough, it seems.
I'm going to push this guy off of the...
live and hope that he dies in real life.
So, can you do it?
Can you take me to the moon?
We can't, but you might be able to.
Why do you want to go there?
I don't know.
Huh?
It's fine.
You can tell us.
It's essential for helping us to get you to go there.
do you want the fame the money you've got to have a motive i'm sorry but i really don't know i just do he saw it on tv yeah i can already tell that this is going to be a pain in the ass it's your job neil nevertheless johnny here's what we will do we need to get to your child but it is too distant to do so in one memory hop.
Thus, we will need to traverse through your memories with gradual backward leaps, which you have given us permission to do in the relative future.
Once we lay down the waypoints in your childhood memories for direct access, we will return here.
That's when you'll need to help us influence the childhood you to become an astronaut.
Change your career trajectory.
Join the space program.
Oh my gosh, we're going to send little Johnny to...
We're going to send little Johnny to space camp.
Or get on a giant catapult.
The point is, you'll need to have more than...
Just...
More...
Wait, you'll need to have more to say than just, I don't know.
As long as you can take me to the moon, I will cooperate in any way possible.
Good.
I wanted to go to space camp.
It was so bad when I was a kid.
Now, in order to leap to a memory, we need an item that is of importance, Sayo.
Do you have a memento of some sort to get us started?
That'll do.
That'll do, don't you?
Well, shall we?
Ladies first.
A mintmento of...
a momento, if you would.
Received note.
We'll need to prepare this momento first.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Complete the momento.
Click the orbs to flip the pieces.
Whoa.
Oh.
Memento.
The Memento can now be activated for traversal.
Activate?
Wait.
Does he have anything else to say?
No?
To the past!
Wait, what about my privacy?
Well, try not to violate what we can avoid.
But in most cases, it can't be held.
I think you should have thought about that before you ask them to go through your memory.
I think you should have Did they not Talk about that in like the orientation The terms and conditions Johnny did you read them But in most cases it can't be helped
Oh whoa Oh Oh grief is so so strange.
Wait.
Turn off visibility and interactivity.
It'd be messy to be seen.
Yeah, yeah.
Happy?
Why do you have to be as smart as smarty pants about everything?
Thank you, Fokuro!
You're okay, I guess.
Jeez, what's with all these rabbits?
This is creeping me out we probably should have checked his record for psychopathy first did he hear me that's impossible it's probably just a part of his memory oh then i stand by my point anyway quick blabbering and find a memento here to hop from
interact with objects to establish five memory links This clock is moving, but soundless.
Okay, we got the clock.
This is so interesting.
Happy Ochi Day, Vito.
Thank you!
Wait, what is this?
Requires memory links to shoot, okay?
We're shooting the umbrella.
Okay, platypus is no goal.
Does this count?
Multicolored favorite rabbit.
Aren't you special having two colors when all your siblings look like they drowned in bleach?
Happy Yoshi Day!
Thank you!
What's that?
You think you're really creepy?
Why, yes, I agree!
Okay, that does count.
Uh, we can go upstairs.
Corvia, thank you so much for the...
for the... for the dono, thank you!
Oh, whoa, whoa!
An old and patched up backpack.
What is this?
A million years old?
I guess we'll find out.
Does that not count?
Okay, what's this?
A glass bottle of pickled olives.
I don't like olives.
Do you guys like olives?
I hate this stuff.
What's it hate?
It's pickled olive.
Not really.
Olives are great.
I just...
I can't get into them.
Happy Yoshi Deminto.
Thank you so much!
Okay, olives count.
Don't.
If we have to explain our presence to him at every memory, I'd go crazy.
Don't tempt me.
Okay.
Um...
Is there anything else that you guys saw?
Pew!
I think I need two more things.
That acidity, the saltiness, the juiciness, perfection.
I see.
I can't go in here.
Can I go outside?
How can you hate a food that when you say it sounds, say it fast sounds like I love.
Olive, olive, olive, olive, olive, olive, olive, olive, olive, olive, olive.
I missed one upstairs.
Okay, thank you.
Oh.
Yep.
Oh, there it is.
The emperor's new clothes.
Okay.
Apparently he really likes that book.
Oh, here.
A selection of readings for medical journals.
Sounds more like Olive.
Yeah, there was a movie about that.
Do you guys remember Olive, the other reindeer?
Oh, here.
Fresh wildflowers.
Okay, I got them.
Do you guys remember Olive the other reindeer?
That was like a, it was a movie about a dog.
His name was Olive.
And he thought that when the song, or when Santa was talking about all of the other reindeers in the song, you know, all of the other reindeer, then that Santa was actually talking about him, the dog.
Olive is a girl.
Oh, my bad.
It's been a really long time since I've seen that movie.
It's so dumb.
It really is.
It's so...
It's like cute and stupid at the same time.
Pew!
How do I get?
What the...
Wait.
I thought I had.
I thought I had a beep
I don't Sorry I just had people cheering
What the Oh frog button sorry What the What's that This game is like being an RPGM without HD Stop don't say that What That's it I'm doing the braking from now on.
Alright, let's travel back!
Oh.
Reminder, the corner orb can flip the entire diagonal.
Sounds like you want me to do that.
Oh wait.
I think I had it.
My bad.
With the ding dong!
Activate the momento.
Wait.
Can I talk to him?
No?
Peepoo peep up.
Aww.
This is so sad.
When it comes to rain, through is better than on too.
I don't mind it regardless.
Seems like these memory hops only span a short period of time.
find a leaping memento, or it's going to take forever.
Just enjoy the scenery.
In memory of River E.
Wiles.
Stuffed toy platypus.
Honestly, oh, why did that door just open?
I don't think this animal has the right to exist.
A shot!
Nobody asked for your opinion, Neil.
The world's not big enough for two of you.
Okay, I think we gotta go in here.
What's wrong with the platypus?
It's finished, River.
Like you, I'll be able to watch over her every day.
She won't be alone anymore.
Did they have like a daughter?
I might never understand why, but I stayed true to your wish.
I'm sure Anya is grateful to you too.
But when I'm gone,
Who is going to watch over us?
Platypus has a right to exist, exactly.
Who are you?
My name is Eva.
Eva?
I was just passing by.
Was she your wife?
Yes.
Her name was River.
her.
That's a special name.
It didn't need to happen.
She... She didn't need to do it.
But she... You wouldn't understand.
I don't even understand.
What?
He didn't say lolly loo, you guys.
He's not Adam.
He's Johnny.
Let the guy grieve in peace.
Thanks for the clarification.
Of course I got you.
Received note.
Anya.
It's about time you got here.
I almost thought you fell off the cliff.
What were you doing?
Enjoying the scenery.
What else?
Any luck here?
huge dinosauric did you guys see that there's the neo tyrannosaur that it's real it's kind of crazy and seven cat welcome the membership thank you
yeah they discovered a new the tyrannosaurus has like a little cousin they've been like the bones a long time ago apparently and then only recently did they find like the thing that makes it like official i can't quite describe it right now do you mean nano yeah nano tyranus yeah
yeah they designated it a species of its own yeah it's cool He's smaller.
This place looks pretty empty.
It's a lighthouse.
What do you expect?
Anyway, I'll catch you on the other side.
Have fun re-breaking the barrier for yourself.
Is it okay?
Oh!
Wait, what does this do?
A broken lighthouse lamp.
Is it okay?
Oh.
Old man.
Ah.
Ha-ya!
Oh.
Ideal shows the minimum number of moves the Memento can be completed in.
What the heck?
Okay.
Why is this like a...
Oh, I think I got it wrong already.
The ideal is three.
like par now?
I did it in four.
I suck.
Oh, man.
Activate.
Skill check.
The bogey.
Whoa.
Oh, he's young.
And all the rabbits are everywhere.
Do you guys hear the heartbeat?
Just enough.
after we pay for your operation we'll have just enough left for for it so don't you worry white lie that's what you call it right no I'm sure we could just stop it
I don't like it when you lie I calculated our finances I know how it's like why do you try to convince me against my will we need the money for your medical bills river I understand that Anya means a lot to you but this this is just too much I mean she she isn't even you know what makes me happy Johnny well
I do I just hope you can help me with it
River.
When the papers for my treatments get here, I will not sign them.
No!
What you do with our money is up to you.
But if you would grant my wish, I want you to use it to finish building that house.
And then, for every day that you live there, I want you to watch over her.
Visit her, speak to her, comfort her.
Is Anya the platypus?
I don't want her to be alone anymore.
And what about you?
I'll be happy.
Johnny?
Yes.
I made this.
Oh, it's the special one.
What?
Just tell me what it is.
It's a bunny.
It's a rabbit.
Like all the others you made.
You guys are all crying.
Are you okay?
What else?
Um, it's made of paper.
Its body is yellow and the rest is blue.
Be depressed for another week.
It's okay, you'll be okay.
Good.
What else?
Look, River...
I wrote a song.
It's for you.
Okay.
Well, would you like to hear it?
Yes.
You didn't have to bring the piano in here for this.
Okay.
I can hear you just fine with the door open.
It's called Four River.
Why so cliche?
It's just a placeholder.
Aw, but it wasn't.
Who is this Anya they were talking about?
If she's so important, shouldn't we have seen her in his late memories?
I guess he didn't keep that promise after.
all unless unless what hey
that's the same song the kids were playing earlier huh i guess he taught them
you know what i'm too manly for this i'm heading on i've already got my memory links you want to hitch a quick ride or look around yourself we'll explore yeah go on ahead on catch up with you.
No, you missed the days when memory audio to MP8 conversion was legal.
Vivi Koi, thank you so much for that gift, dude.
Yeah, Neil is leaving because he's gonna start crying his little baby eyes out.
MP8.
I think I brought home over 2,000 songs during my first year on this job.
Okay, so this This is the...
Okay.
We got the little plat...
Oh, nope.
The emperor's new clothes once again.
A paper rabbit.
The four river.
Downstairs.
Oh!
Oh, is this them bringing up the...
We got some mixed dough.
And we got the olives.
Someone really likes these.
Who is this?
Nicholas, I'm telling you, there's just no way.
What if we take it apart?
Look at us, John.
We aren't exactly at the ripe age of piano moving.
You can read the note.
Wait, how?
You know what?
If this means that much to you, I'll pay for the professionals to do it.
In the menu.
I can't help saving that house for you, so this is the least I can do.
Oh, press escape.
The
moon and Johnny's memory is full.
To the past!
Prepare the memento.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Peep, beep, beep, beep.
Ideal is four.
Uh, I think I'm not good at this game.
Let's see.
I'm just not going to worry about it, I think.
Does it...
Oh, see, I didn't even notice.
It's fine.
Wait.
Am I stupid?
Why can't...
At least it's not Sudoku.
Oh, no, wait.
Oh, gosh.
These are tricky.
Oh, wait.
This doesn't, like, affect an ending, does it?
VTuber, you need to do the puzzle in three seconds.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, the pressure.
It doesn't?
Okay, good.
I was going to say.
It's just your pride.
Yeah.
Is this a corner?
No.
It's my pride.
Wait.
I think I am stupid, though.
How are you supposed to get these?
I've never been good with these types of puzzles.
How are you supposed to get it?
I had it?
I did?
I'm stupid.
No, I'm stupid.
The ideal is four.
And I have it at...
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
How do I reset it?
I actually don't know if I even can.
I would like to.
Wait, can I?
Oh, exit game.
Oh, wait, that exited the whole game.
My bad.
Oh, again?
Please say psych right now.
Say psych right now.
Oh, say psych right now.
Uh-oh.
El Tigre!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the pink.
Wait.
What auto-save?
Oh!
Okay, we're...
Everybody, we're fine.
Save the game.
Guys, we were lucky duckies.
I did, I did.
We're all good now.
We're all good.
Okay, hold on.
Ideal is four?
You worked out so bad.
Hint diagonal.
You need a diagonal, I do.
Oh, I see it.
Thank you guys.
We got that!
We got the ideal!
Yippee!
Diagonal, Vituper Diagonal!
First try.
I totally didn't rage quit the first time.
I thought it meant to like exit the minigame, but it just meant the entire thing.
Finally.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh.
Oh, we're just hopping.
Whoa, whoa.
We're hopping.
Heh.
Look what we have here.
Now, Ed, thank you so much for the video.
Thank you.
Yeah, I did exit the minigame.
They're building the house.
They're forever home.
I bet they saw this cliff and thought it was not dating.
dangerous enough without people living on it.
Oh, he looks tired.
Are you okay, Papa?
Isabel.
Nick called and said I should come.
I brought you pickled olives.
They're your favorite, right?
We should just put some on the ground.
I heard about river.
be okay.
Our illness was just diagnosed in its late stage.
Fortunately, it's treatable.
But the medical bills...
We can't afford to finish building this house, Isabel.
Give me one second.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I thought the music would keep going.
Uh...
There we go.
I realized.
Uh...
There we go.
I can't afford to finish building this house, Isabel.
Well, I can barely afford to pay for her treatment.
I'm just relieved that she'll be okay, but...
You don't know how much this place means to her.
She's going to be heartbroken.
I'd help, but Ted and I have been barely getting by since the market crashed.
Oh, no!
What are you going to do?
do now.
I'm going to tell her that we can make it.
I'm going to tell her that we can afford everything.
I don't want her to do anything crazy.
You shouldn't lie to her.
You don't understand, Isabel.
If she found out, I'm not sure which she'd choose.
So what?
If she chooses not to save herself for the sake of this place, then so be it.
Oh my Oh my gosh!
Somebody...
What?
Poor Johnny!
Oh my gosh!
Crypto stalks, no!
That's what she really wants.
So what?
I really dislike when you neurotypicals think you know what's best for others.
I hate when you call me that, Izzy.
Huh?
Do you think this is all about her?
What about me, Isabel?
After all these years, am I not allowed to be selfish even once?
I don't want to be alone, Isabel.
Aww.
I'm not going to let her die.
That's arrogant.
What is this?
It's not like they're pulling the plug on her.
It's treatable, no?
like am I am I taking crazy pills huh
why are they so mean to him I don't care where are you going I'm going to pick something from this cliff to bring back to her it'll at least give her some comfort it'll make sense later?
Okay, okay.
Right now I'm like, what?
That doesn't make what you're doing any less wrong.
Nick wanted me to give you this.
He said it's called Everything's Alright.
It isn't.
It's a complicated situation.
Neither of them are fully in the wrong IMO.
That can be one of those kinds of situations, I guess.
olive oh okay the olives are the thing
what else we got around here oh the truck the whole truck okay
anything down here nope a rope no oh i'm stuck on a tree okay Hmm.
Inside the house maybe?
Memory links may be acquired from exploration.
Oh, interesting.
Why music box make me so emoy?
Emo sugiro!
Too emotional.
Oh, we got the rest?
Uh...
Come here, olives.
Hiya!
Step twice in the river.
I missed what it said.
I wonder if there- is there like things in here?
I kind of...
Wait, what's the- what's the difference?
Oh, okay okay okay.
Oh!
Huh?
Does it- what color does it need to be?
Wait, I'm confused.
Well, I think I got it.
Pickled olives.
Activate.
Kind of makes me hungry.
A little bit.
Oh, pizza.
Oh, it's ours.
So you guys are really going for it, huh?
It's been a while since I've been able to say hello.
So hello.
Hello.
Thank you, golden pizza.
Thank you.
But I don't like olives.
Yeah.
Yep.
The construction's starting in just a few months.
It's a bit of a squeeze.
We had to split the payment.
But with financing, we'll make do.
How wonderful.
Having your dream house built at such a beautiful site.
You had your wedding at that lighthouse near there all those years ago, didn't you?
Aw, it's nice.
special place.
Oh, that's not all that's special about it.
Oh.
Just kidding.
We have a long history with that place.
Oh, it is their special place.
Well, it's good to have some good news at a get-together for once.
Cheers and congratulations, you two.
Hey, cheers.
Cheers!
And the pickles and the olives.
Be right back.
I'm gonna get some fresh air.
It is special.
It's their special place.
Well, buddy, it's sure...
It's sure been a while.
Hasn't it?
Who knew how hard it is to get across a few cities nowadays?
That river.
Still so quiet, huh?
Eh, she's actually been talkative at home.
I'm with Isabel.
I guess she's just not used to you.
Ha ha ha, so I'm the bad guy here, huh?
Huh?
Oh, hey.
Did you tell River that thing from back then?
So ominous.
I did.
So how did she take it?
For the most part, she took it well.
But something bugs me.
That thing from that time?
That place?
The thing?
Ever since the incident, she's been making these strange rabbits out of paper.
rabbits?
Yeah.
Oregarmy.
Lots of them.
Ha.
I used to fold Oregarmy animals for my daughter all the time.
What's wrong with that?
I don't think it's the same thing.
She's been doing nothing but making the same rabbits.
Day in and day out.
Our house is literally filled with them now.
Didn't Isabel say that something... That something like that?
as a common trait with River's condition?
Yes, but something doesn't feel right this time.
When I ask her about it, she never answers.
Instead, she gets this distant look in her eyes.
It's almost as if she wants something from me.
And the strange thing is, I feel like there's something I owe her to.
The ghost bartender is spooky.
Have you asked, Isabel?
yes she said she talked to her about it but got nothing
well I'm certainly not one to inquire but I'll tell you this I've known you since middle school and you're notorious for overthinking you're probably just imagining things there's no need to get too worked up huh?
usually when someone says that something always goes wrong but I'll give you the benefit of the doubt you're probably right probably I'm always right, John cheers jugs the olive juice wait, so even himself never knew what was up with those rabbits forget about the stupid rabbits we've got bigger problems it's a confined memory and there's no there are no mementos anywhere don't worry,
we can probably draw one out from him how leave it to me I gotta give the book bartender a quick visit for us oh no we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna make him drunk this is this is just like all my other games oh bartender hey there could i get you anything the good old howlinging method yeah hey yo can i get a bottle of picket pickled olives please
I'm sorry.
We don't take checks.
Oh, just put it on my tab then.
Wait, does that mean you don't have any money?
You're so getting resetted.
Hey there, could I get you anything?
Hello.
Could I get a bottle of pickled olives, please?
Sure, cash or credit.
Just put it on my tab.
I feel like spending big today.
Oh, thank you, sir.
Thanks, bro.
You'll be getting an enormous amount of tips today.
Thank you, sir.
You're such an ass, Neil.
Oh, loosen up.
Okay, so we...
Why, is that a bottle of pickled olives you're sporting?
Yeah?
Are you a fellow olive lover?
Indeed I am.
Just got a fresh bottle of them myself, in fact.
Mind if I join you?
Sure, why don't you grab a seat?
We'll down a bottle together.
This is boyhood.
This is the true spirit of boyhood.
Getting a whole jar of olives and just chugging it.
Oh, yeah, that sounds just swell.
Keep up.
Disable taste simulation.
Now!
Good thing is...
Just olives and non-vitical ethanol.
Oh, Neil.
I don't feel like it.
I don't think I feel like it.
I'm so gonna get you back for this.
Chugga chugga.
So that's how we got our first toaster.
Oh.
Ah.
You okay there?
Yes.
I'm just savoring the amazingness of pickled olives.
Olive juice.
Mint.
That's what I said, though.
Olive juice.
There are olives that are pickled in wine?
You're getting late at the night.
They're wonderful, aren't they?
Yeah.
I just can't understand how anyone could find such things to be disgusting.
Say olive juice while holding your tongue.
Olive juice.
Olive.
What
am I saying?
Olive juice.
Olive.
She loves us!
She loves us.
Take your time!
We've got two bottles left!
This is so silly.
So I said, hey, that's not right!
And they totally agreed!
Counselorship, thank you so much for the big!
Happy to see you play this classic.
I'm happy to play it too!
You know what else is wrong with society today?
Yeah, actually I have it right here.
Why?
May I see it?
Uh, okay.
Here it is.
And freeze!
Finally, dear Lord!
How are the olives, Neil?
Oh, shut your mouth.
What is this?
Wait.
I can't stop yawning.
Sorry, guys.
Don't you dare.
Don't worry.
Sheesh.
See, I'm doing it by the books.
What was he doing?
Hulk smash!
Neil, seriously?
Trying to get into this and you're ruining the mood.
Totally worth it.
Yeah, he is a doobly.
Oh,
this one's kind of awkward looking.
Wait, like...
Um...
Wait, okay.
Is it supposed to...
That's copyrighted!
I had it?
I did?
Wait, only...
line i can't i can't it's it's supposed it's supposed to be darker right i was just it's not as hard as it looks there we go it's because the background was darker than the foreground or the whatever that's fine activate memento what is this
Oh my gosh!
They're so young!
Little babies.
Wow, a beautiful sunset.
Isn't it kind of dangerous that there's just this like island and the lighthouse doesn't work?
Crikey, nutcrackers!
You aren't Australian.
Who cares?
We're like 200 billion nanometers off the ground and standing on a damn flagpole.
Just jump down.
It's not like you can be hurt here.
Are you kidding me?
It's a freaking skydive.
You can't stay on here.
You can't get off.
God, I hate when this happens.
You're just gonna push him.
Eva, what the?
Woos.
No fall damage.
It's fine.
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh.
why would they abandon her like this I suppose she's just no longer needed no longer needed by ships I mean you know how it is now that everything has GPS and all that I still think even with GPS they're still necessary no look river
This place means a lot to me too, and I've been thinking.
In our current state, things have been pretty stable.
If we save well in a few years, we could afford to build a house on top of here.
We'd be able to see her from the window!
In the morning, at night, we'd always be nearby.
And... and we could walk here any time.
She'll never be alone again, John!
I'll be able to watch over her every day.
Yeah, we will.
Whoa.
Good for them.
You gotta be kidding me.
You remember what happens, don't you?
It's like watching a train wreck.
The ending isn't any more important than any...
of the memories or any of the moments leading up to it.
The important thing is that over here, they are happy.
Let's move on.
Hold on, I'm going to take a cough drop real quick.
Sorry, guys.
Well, look at them.
Cute.
For some reason, I had it in my brain that this game was voiced, so...
Wait a minute.
They were referring to the lighthouse as Anya, weren't they?
I suppose so.
Then that river, she declined treatment for the sake of a lighthouse?
Am I sick?
No, I think I've just been talking a lot lately, so my throat is a little icky.
But I'll have some days off next week, so it's okay.
I will not talk so much.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Isn't that a bit too extreme?
I've seen stranger things in the course of the job.
Me too, but I can never wrap my head around it.
It's none of our business anyway.
She's not our client.
Anya.
So it's the lighthouse?
No.
Oh, gosh!
It scared me!
Freaky!
We passed right through them!
Oh, we got out.
Wait.
There's a rabbit here.
Oh, this is the thing.
I guess there's probably not anything else for us.
Yeah, okay.
Why is it here, though?
It's kind of weird.
Happy Aussie Day!
Thank you!
Prepare the Memento.
Let's see.
Okay, the ideal is five.
That makes me scared.
Wait.
I'm not good at like mapping these out in my head.
You know what I mean?
Uh...
Memento, hi wisps.
Hello!
Hello, hello!
If it's not checkerboard, you need a diagonal move.
Ah!
Brute force, Azoy.
Now it's Checker.
Wow, that hint actually helped so much.
That actually helped like a ton, thank you.
That makes it easier, doesn't it?
Yeah!
Good job!
No!
Oh, you guys helped me.
Little bunny.
River?
Oh, gosh.
A yellow paper rabbit.
Dear Lord, not again.
Is River already getting sick?
I wonder.
Uh, uh, uh, wait.
There we go.
Mm-hmm.
An old baby grand piano.
How the heck did they move this thing upstairs?
Who knows?
But I bet it'd be a piece of cake for the TARDIS!
Why is this guy allowed to talk?
Not really.
You can't even get it through the door.
True.
Well, that settles it.
Moving pianos is a pain in the arse for everybody.
It'd probably take an entire episode to get it inside.
I wouldn't mind seeing such an episode.
Me neither.
It sounds pretty epic.
Wait, I thought I saw this.
New boxes of plain paper?
Uh-oh.
I think I know where this is going.
Oh!
You went out for a haircut this early in the morning?
What are you making there?
Rabbits.
Did you see the rabbit I left for you?
Yeah.
Tell me about that rabbit.
Huh?
Describe the rabbit.
One...
Was it yellow?
What else?
A bit puffy.
And?
Well, it's just a paper rabbit.
I don't know how else to describe it.
Describe the rabbit.
Hmm?
You're acting strange, River.
Is something wrong?
River?
I'm confused.
I don't know about you, but I'm getting some inverse deja vu.
I think I know of her condition, but this is rather odd even for that.
You think she's...
Do you?
Am I stupid?
What are they inferring?
Perhaps, who knows?
You think she's...
She is Minto.
But like you said, she's not our client.
Origarmi.
Let's just get what we're paid for over with.
Many long strands of orange hair.
That's not good.
Okay, we found the...
It's a platypus.
So this is the day she started it, huh?
No, no spoilers, guys.
No spoilers.
If I ask questions, sometimes they're just like for me to talk out loud.
Let's prepare the minamindu.
Three ideal.
Okay, so if I do this...
Oh, I misclicked!
Oopsie Yippee The platypus
I misclicked
Um...
Like how he's like hiding under the car Oh my gosh, not in the middle of the roads But it's scary
This way?
Oh.
The music is so somber.
Oh no!
It's making me feel kind of weird.
Kind of weird.
So there shouldn't be, I guess there's nothing here.
Like their house has not been built.
This is where the house used to be, isn't it?
The house that never should have been.
I mean, really.
What is it about unusually high and dangerous places attract people new note acrophobia how is that a new note when that is his opinion i kind of okay though i'll be honest you guys i kind of have an obsession with that apartment building in new york city that's just like ridiculously high and now recently it's been like kind of crumbling
have you guys heard of it The toothpick.
The one with the hole in the middle?
Yeah, it has a hole in the middle.
Here, before we get to the story, I'll describe it a little bit.
A healthy obsession, right?
I just like looking into it.
So basically, they made this extremely tall...
Like, it's basically...
I would say a toothpick, but it's actually, like, just a rectangle.
So it's a very tall apartment building.
and um they had to put like holes in it kind of in in it to help with the swaying because it's so tall and so thin and it's not very like wind resistant and like people that live there describe it as like if if you're on the higher floors and it's a it's a windy day they describe it like as bad as a boat rocking.
And 432 Park Ave?
I believe that's the name of it.
I'm not good with numbers.
And also...
And also, they didn't...
They didn't account for like...
I guess...
I don't even know, like padding?
I don't even know how to describe it.
But when they drop...
When they drop their garbage down, the garbage chute from like the higher floors.
It is going straight down.
It is going down, down, down.
And then people have described that the noise when it drops is so loud that it sounds like a bomb is going off.
Like it is.
And the people that built it, they were like, we want to build this out of concrete, but we want it to be aesthetically pleasing.
So they were told if they built it out of white concrete.
that it would crack and so that but they were like no we want it to look good so we'll do that and so now it is starting to crack and chip and like little pieces are falling from like these thousands of feet in the air whatever the hell and like dropping onto the ground which you know if it's going at that kind of speed it's going to literally be like a bullet to somebody's head and they were told this they were told that it will crack if they use they could go with the white concrete or they could go with regular concrete and it would be more sturdy and they were like nah we want it to look good and so now the people that are living there are the ones having to foot the bill to repair the building and like power outages go happen all the time and people get trapped in the elevator and it's just it's just horrible hold on i'm gonna double check if it was oh wait uh
yeah 432 park avenue it's it's almost 1400 feet tall and there's concrete falling from there and it's just like it's so ugly
it's so it's so terrible apparently it's designed by the same architect i think he's doing this on purpose i'm not gonna lie because it's designed by the same architect i can't remember his name but he also designed another building somewhere in europe but it was like angled at a in a way that where like the the sun reflecting off the building was literally like melting cars why did they keep letting this guy who Who gave this guy a degree?
He's notorious.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one in London.
Is that where it's at?
Oh, gosh.
Like, who allowed this guy to have an architecture degree?
Who passed his class?
Anyway.
Why did I start talking about that?
I don't remember.
But yeah, look up 432 Park Avenue if you want, like, it's kind of insane.
Okay.
Back to...
Oh, the acrophobia!
That's right, the heights.
Crazy.
I don't have a fear of heights, though.
I'll live at the 432 Park Avenue.
I'll take one for the team.
Back to Gim.
River, says.
Is that why you approached me back then?
Fallen, thank you so much for the big!
Natural born weapons designer decides to work in architecture.
Yeah.
What about now?
I suppose it's just a part of it.
Look, it was a long time ago.
It's not too relevant now.
But Izzy said, I should tell you the truth.
I shouldn't have tainted our first meeting like that.
What?
Huh?
Oh.
Is she not?
What is that?
A hacky sack?
You're a diehard wisp and you want to see Mito ahead of the other wisp?
What do you mean?
Can you throw this as far as where Anya's out?
I don't know.
You want me to try?
Would you?
Whoa.
River!
Are you insane?
Get away from there!
What?
I think this memory isn't too far from the last.
I think they may be connected?
Probably.
Oh.
Wait, I'm trying to...
It says I can go this way.
but oh i have to click maybe oh there we go okay uh this one why did she cut her hair anyway i like long hair who cares what you like kneel
yeah i liked her with long hair
it didn't look like she cut it so short am i crazy prepare the memento
One, two, three, three, four.
Easy.
Activate memento.
She's gaming!
Genius, genius, genius!
Stab!
Everyone with it is different, John.
just because she and I share the syndrome doesn't mean we share the same head but you must be able to help somehow everything was okay at first but now she's even more aloof than before syndrome Chunibio syndrome even when we're in the same room she's never really there it's starting to take a toll on me.
Trash boy, thank you so much.
Welcome back.
I just don't know how to take it anymore.
Well, I can't speak for her, but many of us do long for connections.
Though, being able to articulate it is a different story.
Just because she struggles to express it doesn't mean she doesn't feel anything.
She's still there, right?
Sometimes you just have to have faith that she cares.
Happy OECD.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Hope your cat has stopped farting when you hug them.
Thank you, Walt.
Thank you so much.
That's pretty difficult to do day in and day out.
I know.
I've just stopped holding her.
My cat.
Wait, but why do you seem so normal, is he?
I mean, don't you have the same condition?
For one, I was diagnosed when I was still young.
With effort, it's not impossible to acquire a guise of social norms systematically.
But you know what?
I both envy and pity River.
Me, I'm an actress, because I've been doing it all my life.
Not only on stage, but offstage, and at practically every moment.
good at it because acting is the only option I have.
It's the only way for me to be normal.
Well, River, she never did that.
She remained an outcast and refused to learn to step against it.
I don't know if it was by choice or by limit, whether bravery or cowardice.
There are days when I just can't stand faking it anymore.
And then I realize that it's too late.
The Isabel that people know know of is all an act and the real me has long become a stranger.
I think in the end I just envy her.
I've never met a woman with it before.
Then technically you still haven't met one.
This isn't part of our business.
Let's move.
Why are they like not saying anything?
Like it's taboo to say.
Like is it autism?
Is it just taboo to say that for some reason?
The world would be a lot more beautiful if people just remembered faces more.
Anything new today?
No.
Different times.
It's an old game.
Oh, this game is from 2011?
Ah!
I guess that makes sense.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
What are you rereading there?
The Emperor's New Clothes.
I love this when I was young.
Still do, huh?
Of course.
Just for different reasons.
When I was a kid, I loved the Animorph series.
I know.
Your mother gave you a book from it as a wedding present.
Whoa!
Some people ask for pots and pans And other people ask for Animorphs books
That's crazy Read this, Johnny Read this and remember that your love is always transforming Like an Animorph
The wedding registry is just the whole series
Animorphs is goaded though I'm not saying it's not.
I just think it's a wild thing for a wedding gift.
Yeah.
That was one odd wedding present.
Okay, at least he acknowledges that.
I guess I was pretty obsessed with it when I was a kid.
Why haven't you read them since?
Hmm?
I saw them.
They're collecting dust in the garage.
His dad gave him a copy of the emperor's new clothes.
Hmm?
Well, I just grew out of them, I guess.
I mean, they're children's books.
What's wrong with reading children's books?
They're comforting.
I suppose so.
I don't know.
The Animorph series is kind of messed up.
I don't think it's very comforting at all.
Some kids get stuck as animals.
I think I'm going to get this one.
Xenomorphs is dark.
It's not like a...
Whoa.
I'm not yours.
You're not mine.
Be my anti-Valentine.
Hey, River.
This one's not that corny.
River?
Be my anti-Valentine.
But what about David's?
He's my favorite character.
I don't know.
What are you talking about?
Animorphs?
Have you read it?
No.
Yes.
Really?
Sort of.
Oh, whoa.
Do you know what animal is David's main morph?
Um.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Um.
Uh, David.
David.
I'm gonna guess a hawk.
I don't know.
A bird.
Hawk!
That doesn't sound right.
Don't worry, I'll find it out for you.
I got- what is it?
Wait, can I do it again?
Oh, I can, I can!
Snake- wait, if it's David...
No!
It couldn't!
What do you mean it's not a snake?
You can find the answer, or can I?
Uh...
Your mom...
Okay, hold on.
Let's go find it.
Maybe somebody knows the answer.
Can I research it?
Oh.
Okay, it's that book.
Uh...
Okay.
Animorphs.
No elf?
I'm gonna Google it then.
David and Morphs.
David is the villain.
What is he transforming to?
What's his morph?
What's his main morph?
I'm having...
He found the morphing cube.
What can he turn...
Yurk?
No.
She's cheating.
It's called using your resources.
Oh wait, to the moon is awesome.
There's a thing.
No stinking way.
I was close!
It's a cobra!
No stinking way!
I really wish they kept the old covers instead of these plain sheets.
They were so cool.
It's a kind of snake.
Tobias Hawk.
I was close.
Oh, wait.
She would have told us.
Rachel Grizzly.
Jake Tiger.
Marco Gorilla.
David Cobra.
Cassie Wolf.
Why?
Oh, just wondering.
I...
Why did I guess Hawk?
How did I guess it?
And then it also was a type of snake.
Crazy.
You could have just Googled it.
I did, actually.
River calling me out.
No?
I did Google it.
I was just talking to her.
Prepare the memento.
No!
Uh-oh.
This seems tricky.
Wait a second.
No, it's not.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Easy peasy.
Animorphs.
This is so crazy.
I can't believe Animorphs has such a big part of this story.
Wait, are we at their wedding?
The olive juices are in here too.
Aw, everyone's leaving already, but I just got here.
Kita bakari!
Seems to happen to you a lot of parties.
Oh, go save your childish jabs for the insecure.
A glass bottle of pickled olives.
I see the foiege, but where is the mouse?
That's the corneous remark you've made all night.
Anamorphs is a core memory, it seems.
So true.
Don't you mean cheesiest remark?
Wow.
Aged Anamorphs book.
This person looks like they're covered in blood or something.
What's going on there?
Huh?
Oh gosh, it's like impossible getting through these tiny little tables and stuff.
Excuse me.
Why did I get over here?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, sorry I didn't see who ran it, but thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you guys for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh, it is their wedding!
Oh my gosh.
Why do they look so sad?
Oh.
Wait, I didn't...
Wait, what's going on?
Do you feel any different?
Now that we've got the rings on, I mean?
Oh my gosh.
Her dress colors!
You're right!
No.
Why, do you?
Actually, yeah, I think so.
What is it like?
It's just different.
I know some of you are married.
In my chat, you've told me.
Did you feel any different?
I don't think I've ever thought about it.
Because it's like...
I've never thought about it.
Does it feel different?
Yeah, to meintosh.
I feel like if I...
I don't know.
You marriage!
Not really, to be honest.
No difference with me because we were already living together so long before getting married.
Oh, that makes sense.
Will you marry me?
Take a girl to dinner first.
Try it on and see?
We are...
We're married, aren't we?
When's our ceremony?
We haven't had the ceremony, Arca.
Taxes will never be the same.
Filing joy, baby.
Will
you marry me?
Kermit voice.
You want the Kermit voice?
I learned recently that my voice for Kermit doesn't sound like Kermit at all.
I think I didn't know what Kermit sounded like.
I think I...
Like, I always thought Kermit kind of sounded like this, but then I listened to Kermit and I was like, whoa, this just sounds like a, like a dude.
I'm closer to the, what's his name?
The guy that made the puppets.
He was the voice.
I'm Jim Henson, yeah.
I'm Jim Henson, Kermit.
I'm Miss Piggy.
While David had a pet cobra, he never morphed it.
His man morph was a lot... Oh, wait, are you...
Are you... I'm actuallying the game?
His man morph was a lion because he wanted to one-up Jake, whose man morph was a tiger.
Oh my gosh!
Happy Oshi Day to Frog Bird.
Thank you.
Yeah, every day should be Yoshi day for me.
Okay, back to the game, sorry.
It's different.
Just the responsibilities, I suppose.
Okay, okay.
Responsibilities.
Do you like the name Anya?
Oh?
Would you like...
Would you like to name her Anya?
I understand.
What?
I don't.
Well, he's the one that married her.
He should get her more than...
Anya's a good name for her.
He should get her more than any of us.
Hey, come with me!
They're cute.
They're cute!
This can't be a good idea.
trip and fall.
Don't worry, just follow my steps.
Are they kissing?
Ow, my ass!
I think you stepped on my toes.
Sorry.
Come on, let's try again.
Okay.
Oh my god, they danced until sunrise.
They...
danced.
First time, thank you!
Thank you so much for the pink.
To promise to love and comfort and honor and to keep in sickness and in health for as long as you shall live.
I do.
And do you take this man standing?
Oh my gosh, wait, I could be like, actually being the one officiated maid, officiated.
officially being the one I'm I'm doing the marrying would
you officiate she officiate a wedding I would yeah put me in coach do you take this man standing before you to be your lawfully wedded husband to promise to love and comfort in honor and to keep in sickness and in health for as long as you shall live.
That's exactly how I would say it, too.
By the power invested in me, I now pronounce you husband and wife.
Ladies and gentlemen, I present to you Mr. and Mrs. Wiles.
Yeah, what did you think that was?
And with the power vested in me as Vittobar.
I'm just bad at weddings, that's all.
Fluids tend to escape from my eyes.
My god, they're not escaping from anywhere else.
I didn't know you were that sentimental.
Oh, did I say my eyes?
I meant my mouth.
And by fluids, I meant both fluids and solids.
That's a lovely image.
Thanks, Neo.
Let's find a way to get out of here.
All this happiness and joy is really putting you off too, huh?
Oh my gosh.
Mew is literally like Riaju.
Yucky.
I hate the normies.
No, I just don't like watching people make mistakes.
Are you saying them getting together was a mistake?
Cheesh, whatever happened to just take it moment by moment.
Oh my god.
Make a mistake.
That's crazy.
she looks so pretty though
yeah did she get a divorce or something she doesn't believe in marriage anymore
oh the cake
I better go see how your aunt is doing alright ma tell her thanks for coming I will marriage marriage marriage is what brings us together today i'm so proud of you joey joey nicholas is also feel what oh that's my grandpa's name he passed away before i was born ma calls me at calls me by it as my nickname how come you never told me about it because i'd rather you call me
Not another sentimental grandparent childhood.
Ack.
What do you have against those anyway?
I mean, you should talk about your grandfather a lot.
What?
No, I don't.
Whatever you say.
We got Joey note.
All right, just one more.
And it's not the cake?
This way.
I hear like a boop boop boop oh what is going on over here what is that what is this looks like a decapitated person I can't be helped River I'm sure they didn't mean to come on we're late wait is that a rabbit oh I see it now
John plain name but I won't forget it.
I think this is the source of all those folded paper ones.
Why would she obsess over some roadkill?
Not to mention so many years later.
Don't ask me, you're the woman here.
I'll be convinced that I'm the only one when you do a cordless bungee jump.
You're the female.
Dead robin.
Come on, River, we're late.
I don't want to unlock this.
How is this a Memento?
I thought Mementos are supposed to be special.
Oh, God.
I don't like it.
I don't like it at all.
It's special roadkill.
It's my roadkill.
You know, it's a fantastic wedding when the Memento's roadkill...
That's what happened.
I'm saying!
Hey, maybe she saw it as a metaphor for the terrible marriage.
So years later, she began folding the rabbits because she was reminded of how rotten it was.
Hayden, thank you so much for the 20 gives a thank you.
Or, you know, something equally pretentious.
Cool story, Neil.
Okay.
Aww.
I don't want to see it get run over.
Okay, we are sent to the middle of the road.
Poor thing.
What's with all the road kills today?
Don't you look at me like that?
Smells like a farm.
I had road kill.
Deactivate the scent simulator or get away from here already.
Okay, we'll just- oh, not this way.
Hmm.
Rest in peace, Wabby.
Oh, oh, it scared me.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
What a majestic horse.
Whoa.
Don't do it.
Don't do what?
You know what?
Oh, my God.
He wants to get with the horse.
Don't not ride the horse?
What, are you five years old?
Okay, I won't not ride it.
Hiya!
Quit wasting time, Neil.
Oh, crap.
I can't be good.
Doing something.
Don't just stand there.
Help me!
Damn it.
This was not in the job description.
Dr. Neil Watts.
Okay.
So what are we doing here, huh?
Am I supposed to go after him?
Whoa, whoa, freaky.
I guess I'll go make debut.
I'll go after him, I guess.
I get stuck on bushes.
Hello?
Oh, it's them.
I'm thought with words, but thank you for being here with us and thank you for being by us.
Thank you.
Oh, here we go.
Is that really a good idea?
She should be okay.
She's not new to this anymore.
She has never done it by herself before.
I'll be fine.
I'm not a child.
Whoa.
Ah!
Bruh, fire!
Oh, she's getting it.
Maybe.
Oh, it's the matter.
Let's go!
Whoa.
Hey, wait up!
Can I ride the horse?
I wonder if Neil got off that horse yet.
Eva!
This is about 19% more than I can handle.
This guy.
What a moron.
I couldn't have said it better myself.
Oh, what the cord comb?
I want some corn.
Oh.
Whoa!
We're zooming?
Oh my gosh, we're really zooming.
Move out of the way!
Who are you?
Oh, wait, there they are!
I'm the third wheel.
And their horse date.
I'm third wheeling.
Are you good?
Oh, I got stuck on a rock and then a tree.
We're zooming.
I'm going around.
I'm discovering things.
The rabbit.
I haven't discovered much.
What are you guys looking at?
Hey team?
Oh I got him!
Ow.
Where'd he go?
How do I get off the horse?
Wait, I'm gonna save because I haven't in a minute.
Okay, it did.
Um, oh here we go.
Oh, this is the thing.
Here, this memento will do.
But I'm not getting on that horse again.
You'll go get the rest of the memory links.
Okay.
It saves in horse.
It does.
Wait, should I be like clicking around?
Let's see.
Maybe I click on them.
Can I see them again?
Hello!
Oh I did!
I got him!
Wait, was that everything?
Are you good?
Just hopping a little.
I think I... Was that everything?
For some reason it's not showing up anymore.
Memento!
I did it!
I just noticed it's a full moon tonight.
Not only is it a full moon tonight, it's a super moon.
Let's activate memento.
Beep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
The super moon.
Whoa, I reached to a child.
Is the diagnosis certain?
Yes, we've reached a consensus on the results.
Unfortunately, like many cases of pervasive developmental disorders, this is a rather late diagnosis.
Why is his head, like, morphed into the chair?
He's an animorph.
No, he's a furniture morph.
Have you ever...
Had you known when you were a child, Miss, it could have saved you a lot of trouble.
Do you have any books on it?
This one by Tony Atwood.
He is one of the specialists on the subject.
You can borrow it free of charge for now.
Just don't elope with it.
Thanks, Doc.
Now, are you two a couple?
Unmarried and without any other current legal affiliation.
Yes, I see.
Free book.
Well, I could give you a referral to a specialized counselor if you wish.
Is there anything unsettling in the relationship?
No.
And you, sir?
It's fine.
He's a little hesitant.
Nonetheless, sir, you should also give the book a read.
It'd help you understand her condition.
I'd rather not.
Okay.
Why is that?
Well, it's your call.
In the meantime, there's a thing called Equine Therapy that might help her.
A ranch just north of here offers it.
I can contact them for you.
Well, that author is real, so if you know spoils what...
Oh, interesting.
It's terminal.
The horse girl is terminal.
Told you so.
You can never...
Once you horse girl, you can never stop.
Excuse me, could you please silence the clock?
The ticking really bothers her.
It's not that severe.
I'll be okay.
No problem.
It's standard policy.
If there's anything at all that makes you uncomfortable, just let me know.
Thank you.
I guess that explains the ones in the house.
Oh yeah!
I'm also jumping.
Okay, it's the clock.
Nah, that explains the silent clock.
Tony Atwood.
Hmm.
Oh.
A plain tawny handbag.
Aww.
What else?
Just a bit longer.
They'll be calling for you soon.
Oh, the platypus.
I can't believe this piece of atrocity is dated all the way back here.
Looks like someone took good care of it.
What is just a platypus?
What's wrong with it?
She's still got pretty bad taste in animals, though.
This guy sucks.
Shut up, Neil.
What do you like?
Huh?
Your animal is probably so dumb.
exist you probably like the dodo bird which is also a good animal but because you like it it sucks no
bully near you can't tell me what to do activate the
memento oh the movie theater where
we see it hmm Sst, look, I think, oh my gosh, I still am just craving some movie theater popcorn.
I know, I can't believe he once paid to see this crap in theater.
No, you idiot.
Look, we leaped.
What's the music so scary for?
Holy overcooked macaroni, the kid's in the theater all by himself.
What a loser.
Oh my god.
He's like the comic relief character in the story You go to the theater all by yourself all the time That's different No one's competent enough to match my taste But that aside How could anyone last through this rubbish?
I go lots of places alone You know how people will be like You shouldn't go eat at a restaurant alone Or anything like that I go all the time.
Is it really that bad?
And thus, this movie sucks on both physical and metaphysical levels.
Q-E-Z.
Cheating enough.
Come on, let's go.
What?
Oh, right.
Why is the music so scary?
It's, like, so dramatic.
Oh, I could just grab that person.
Whoa, wait.
I ain't talking to no emo teenager.
Grammar, my dear Watson.
Shut up.
It's not even a full sentence.
I feel weird going places alone, but that's because I have a wife.
Stop bragging.
AMC theaters, pre-pop bags plus Orville poured over oil.
It calls you.
I know!
I gotta get it!
Let's look for the mementos.
Oh, so we're almost to, like, baby.
Actually...
Oh.
Huh?
I'm grabbing the people.
What are you doing?
That's the third person you've removed here.
Eh, it's not like it's permanent.
Did I ever have an emo phase?
I did!
I did, actually.
I was like...
I had like a scene...
I didn't do like the...
What do you call it?
Like the raccoon hair.
But I had like a scene haircut.
And...
You know, all that stuff.
Where are the memories?
I was an emo...
I was an emo kid for a bit.
Not the bathrooms.
It was a phase.
It was, yeah, it was a phase.
You know that poking them out of the way like that does nothing, right?
Then why complain?
Why can't I just erase people's existence?
Getting stood up?
Now that's a Kodak moment.
You relate well with your kin, I see.
Um...
Aw, poor guy got stood up!
I don't know if I'm supposed to remove all the people, so I just will.
Oh look, this place is all empty and creepy now.
I hope you're happy.
Oh, come here.
Uh...
Oh, I made it really creepy.
Wait, I made it weird.
I want to construct him a lady friend.
Can we construct a lady friend for him, Eva?
No.
Aw.
Creepy!
Wait.
There's something still here?
No.
Construct me a lady friend.
Wait, do I have to get rid of...
Wait.
Well, there's nothing here.
I hate to say it, but I guess I have to nag something out of him again.
All yours.
At least there's no olives this time.
Okay, okay.
I thought I was going to have to get rid of all the people in the theater too.
Wait, is this how they meet?
River?
You were in there this whole time?
Oh, okay.
I waited for you at the lobby.
I thought you didn't come.
Why did you leave?
I thought we were watching the movie together.
Huh?
I'm the one who should ask that.
What do you mean?
We were watching the movie together and then you left.
We weren't watching it together.
I didn't even know where you were.
If you saw me in there, why didn't you come and find me?
What difference does it make?
We were watching the same movie in the same room.
Ah.
Of common, silly misunderstanding.
What's wrong?
You're so weird.
cute do you not want to watch the movie together anymore of course I do come let's head back in before it ends aww what a weirdo
how it took till adulthood to figure it out I don't know
she's just quirky
I feel like I I should make a clever remark.
You feel wrong.
Well, let's hope our ride's waiting for us in there.
Hold on, let me drink some more tea.
There were no signs.
Oh.
Oh, it's the platypus again, probably.
I want to know what the movie is.
Whoa.
Uh.
Wait.
Five moves.
Okay, I got it.
Easy peasy.
The Minecraft movie.
They should have stayed.
They would see...
What was it called?
What was the...
The man sandwich or whatever.
You shouldn't go to restaurants alone?
You should go with me instead?
I was driving, so this is a bit late.
Well, where would you want to go?
You know, I think this platypus is growing on me.
Mostly just for convenience, but hey.
Oh.
Where, baby?
I've been craving spaghetti.
Come on, dude, grow some balls.
It's not that.
Look, maybe this wasn't such a good idea.
Oh, sheesh.
What could possibly happen?
Um.
Just think about it.
Worst case scenario, she says no.
You strut on like nothing happened.
No one will know and everyone will still think you're cool.
What if she tells someone?
Or yells at me.
Don't be a little wuss.
Or says yes, but really means no.
Quit worrying.
Oh,
quit worrying.
Quit worrying.
Who would do that?
And what if she throws an encyclopedia in my face?
Can you guys tell I wasn't the cool one in school?
I don't even have a helmet.
Dear Lord, I'm so not prepared for this.
Dude, don't panic.
Just straighten your spine and quit being a little wuss.
Dude, I have scoliosis.
I can't straighten my spine.
Yeah, you tell him.
Everything will be all right.
around.
Okay.
Hey, what are you?
Just let it happen.
Let it happen.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Then why didn't you?
Never mind.
Takai, thank you.
Thank you.
badge thank you the side eye i love her side eye um that's a cool platypus he got there what are you reading a book about platypus no oh i uh i think that's great he's in middle school oh my gosh oh sorry he said something but it went by lighthouses huh there are exactly 16 second order Fresno lands lighthouses in the country left nine of them are coastal and one of them was modified from a historic kerosene lamp lighthouse the signs were never there nobody nobody would have known oh is that what you're reading about
Aw, um, say, you want to go catch a movie together sometime?
She looks so nervous.
It's cute.
I don't know.
That's okay.
I'll give you time to consider it.
I can't.
Why?
There's no date or time.
Oh, um, how about this Saturday at 8?
He just knows the movie time off the top of his head.
Ugh.
I think the system froze yes oh great never mind I guess we'll work out the details later river um I'll just
what what are you looking at me for I'm just gonna come clean you are Akamiyoshi.
Thank you for your brave confession, Green Bear.
Thank you!
You think I'm gonna call out how utterly awkward that was?
Well, just forget it.
I'm not giving into your expectations.
Give him a break.
He was still just a kid.
You of all people should relate.
What's that supposed to mean?
Shut up and go.
my name, you know.
That stuffed platypus.
Well, I suppose if you look at it from the right angle...
No.
Not really.
Never mind.
Such a hater.
She put the book up.
It's so cute.
What the heck were you doing in there, dude?
What?
I asked her out.
No.
That was pathetic.
Why were you?
I would have just barged in there and be all like...
Hey!
Yeah!
out meet you now that's just terrible i know and it's would have still been better than what you just did dang riseless but you know who has maidens johnny anyone anyone at all
all right then River, why don't you answer it?
You know the answer.
I know you know the answer.
We're waiting, River.
Fine.
Oh, he made sale on August 3rd of 1492 from the Spanish city of Palos de la Frontera, which was founded in 1322 and granted to Alvar Perez de Guzman.
Sorry, my horrible white accent.
It was at the mere age of 14 She didn't buy the...
Okay, okay.
I only asked for the date.
But see?
Was that so hard?
Guzman.
Good lord.
Does everyone with her condition have near-photographic memory?
What?
They're so mean.
Not really.
Though I think their...
Rote?
Rote memory is often fairly strong.
Ghostly.
Yeah?
Is there a problem?
Psst, she's coming this way.
Altab, Altab!
What are they doing?
Altab 4, Altab 4!
What are they doing on the school computers?
Locked.
Cafeteria only open during lunch hours.
Scatter.
Scaddle.
Scuddle.
Whoa, P.E.
That's a rep.
You chumps better be better next time.
An atrium.
We could use this place later.
I just can't believe that these court lines are rectangles in his head.
Is that a problem?
I'm going to get rid of this guy.
Oh, it worked.
They're round normally, are they?
Fine.
You win.
Booyah!
Okay, one more.
One more.
I think it was...
Oh, gosh, they went so fast.
Limitations with RPG Maker.
Oh, that makes sense.
Oh, wait!
Oh, go back.
Okay, well, I missed something in the other room.
I didn't see them in the art room or whatever it was.
Booyah.
Yeah, she's unique, but she's unique.
boring I mean just look at her she's so cute what are you talking about she just sits there by herself all day with that creepy deformed duck toy it's not a deformed duck that's a platypus what the heck's a platypus quit making words up you're in middle school and you don't know what a okay Anyway,
she's just so off, you know?
It's like she's from a totally different planet or something.
I know, isn't that cool?
Aww.
If you're into aliens and that sort of stuff, I guess.
Oh my gosh, Johnny grew up to become, like, totally into monster girls.
Alien.
Why does she alien?
But really, if you want to be weird, why don't you go hang with the aliens?
and goths.
Well, for one, I don't want to ruin my hair.
The fact that we got a name for them says a lot, too.
Look, Nick.
I just...
I just don't want to be another typical kid in a sea of typical people.
But how the heck would be in with her change your own identity?
I mean, you'd just be some guy who hangs out with a shy girl.
She's not just shy, Nick.
There's something strange about her.
Being strange isn't always a good thing, you know.
Do you even know if she wants to be different?
Maybe she just wants to fit in like everyone else.
And if she does, pushing her the other way wouldn't help, would it?
Look, Nick, the point is that I know what I need.
Oh my gosh.
And she is the one who has it.
Wow.
It's such a young age.
He knew what he wanted.
So you want her for what she has, but not for her.
That's cold, man.
Is this what he told her?
Why he got with her or whatever?
That made her really upset.
I just hope you know what you're doing.
I do.
I think you're wrong, though.
People aren't that typical.
Everyone's unique in some way.
That's just what grandma's telling you.
So he liked the idea of her.
He didn't like her.
And that made her really upset.
Wait, so this guy is some kind of human hogging hipster?
That's sort of disturbing.
You You know, sometimes I want to slap our clients upside the head.
It's high school.
Everyone's a- Oh, I thought they were in middle school.
Everyone's a bastard.
But hey, welcome to the club.
It is weird.
Wait, so also, if she did want to fit in, he was just like, no, you're going to be hanging out with me.
Wait, so this is what he told her about at the cliff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, that makes it even worse that he didn't know what a platypus was.
He's in high school and didn't know.
He didn't want to read the doctor's pamphlet too.
Yeah, he just kind of was like.
He like rejected it.
I suppose so.
She then went cuckoo and began making those creepy rabbits, right?
Because he confessed this from who knows how long ago?
I guess she's pretty good at holding a grudge.
Cool a James, ain't you?
I'm not buying it.
Something feels missing.
Then go get a hat, Sherlock.
Come on, I think our passport's leaning against the table there.
Strange situation.
I'm envious that this kid was still there to help him move pianos when their hair grew.
I wish I was still in contact with my childhood friends.
Stuffed toy platypus.
I just love how every time we see this thing, we guarantee a free memory link.
It must have left a big...
Left as big of a scar on his mind as it did on mine.
Reasons and intents aside, it's pretty remarkable that they actually met in high school.
How many of those go on for more than a month nowadays, huh?
I don't know about you, but mine went pretty swimmingly.
Yeah?
So swimmingly, it swam right out the window.
Sounds about right.
Literal high school sweethearts?
Is what they call them.
Should I even?
No need.
I'm all good now.
Kame!
Oh, for walnuts' sake.
Hey.
Not cool, Eva.
You never block someone in the middle of a Kamehameha.
What?
She's such a loser.
what's wrong with him don't ever interrupt a man's kamehameha
diagonal vtuber yeah let's try it
wait I still don't get it the easy
peasy wait am i missing it i don't see it at all wait hold on
do you see it
wait uh wait why is this one of eluding me
like i see it but at the same time i'm like wait i don't see it wait oh there we go i see it I got it.
It hit me.
It was so easy.
For some reason, my brains just stopped computing.
Okay, we're good.
It's right there.
I know!
For some reason, my brain stopped computing.
Are we at Baby Johnny now?
I'm going to school now, ma.
Have a nice day, Joey.
My baby boy.
Growing up so fast.
Ghost brain to ethereal at times.
It must be it.
That must be it.
What if he was a girl?
Would she still nickname him after his grandpa?
It wouldn't be that bad, actually, since it ends in A.
Joey.
Julie.
Sounds cute.
If it sounds so cute, why don't you marry him?
What is this?
Ayy.
Ah, jealous?
Oh yes, so jealous.
The clicking clock.
To be fair, a ticking clock is pretty annoying indeed.
I don't think it's that annoying.
Let's go into his room.
But can I go in through here?
Yes.
This is how he...
Oh, the soccer ball, okay?
I cannot get a grasp of like the...
I guess... I'm gonna guess that like this era is like 2011, because that's when the game came out or whatever.
And then the future...
is like the distant future.
Various books with smudge titles.
Oh yeah, okay, it's so slippery.
Okay.
Oh, the olives.
Oh, bleh, not again.
Glass bottle of pickled...
Cucumbers!
Holy crap, my mind's totally blown!
You're pretty easily impressed.
Yeah, he does have a bunk bed.
Hmm.
Curious.
Memento prepare.
See, this one didn't...
This one didn't confuse me.
I got it.
Walk then, you know me.
Suckerball?
Whoa.
Whoa, where are they?
Ack, it smells like roadkill again.
Where are we?
I like how he says, ack.
Eva?
What the hell is that?
Huh?
What is this?
That's his next memory.
Yeah, but why is it going lapida on us?
I don't know.
It's not just linking the memories together for construction.
There must be a malfunction within the machine's ADG.
I thought the last fix was foolproof for another half a year.
I can't believe those idiots in the maintenance department.
Yeah, castle in the sky.
We've already gotten the teenage years saved.
We might still be able to do this.
Alright, but I ain't telling him about this.
As long as we succeed.
He doesn't have to know.
Well, I guess this is it.
There's nothing we can do here.
Ready to finalize before activation?
Okay.
Ladies first.
What a shame.
I was actually looking forward to it.
For Spanish speakers, Lapido sounds pretty bad.
I know.
I've heard that before.
Act two.
Billions of lighthouses.
Stuck at the far end of the sky.
How many acts are there?
Well, this is the halfway point.
Three.
Okay.
Don't disturb them.
They might not wake easily, but they need the concentration.
Well, they're back to him.
And that's all this old fool knows.
Sorry, I can't be more of help.
It's been three hours.
Then that'll have to be enough.
all that's left to do is linking your registered desire to go to the moon to your early memories then we'll pull the switch and voila you'll be on the moon in no time I have a question if you could make Lily disappear that means you can alter this world then can you not simply make things happen and fulfill my wish here and now yeah i was wondering that too why they have to go through like all of this
i'll save i won't let me save until i move around it would work if there were if this were one of your true set of memories what do you mean what is this then what am i this is just a copy the canvas for us to work with if you will as for you you are merely an algorithm traced from Why?
Enough to reflect his likeness, but far from complete.
All we can do is prepare this canvas in a logically consistent way.
And then, when we transfer your registered desire to your childhood, the machine will generate your new life, one where the desire dictates your behavior.
The goal of an NPC!
The result of that would then be written to the real world.
John so you see even if we satisfy you you are merely a red only read only program he's AI he's a ghost in the machine he is oh my god I mean we could reset you over and over again and that's enough oh don't be so sensitive it's It's not real, you know.
But if you truly believe that, why did you even care to explain?
This is so sad!
I'm just trying to save time.
Let's go.
Doctor.
Is that what I truly am?
Couldn't even grace him with an answer!
Oh my god!
What the heck is going on in here?
Ah, all of our nights work.
Whoa.
Oh, so like each, like, old man and teenager, they each have their own four.
Oh, and interesting.
Whoa, what's that over there?
What's that over there?
Interesting.
What the?
He became you guys.
He's a wisp.
What the?
At least give me a warning first.
What can I say?
I like being ahead.
But ask if that's a pun.
But I'm afraid you'd say yes.
Let's do this fast.
I feel silly enough in this form as it is.
All we need to do is pass his desire from the latest memory to the earliest.
Okay, hold on.
They're so silly looking.
Okay.
Line up two matching mementos on the edges to transfer the registered desire.
Uh, does the bunny count, I guess?
Do I have to do it with this one too, then?
Like that?
Uh, the book?
Hey, Eva, check this out!
Nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom.
The first one isn't connected.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Because I had to move it.
Would it be connected to the...
Oh, the...
Oh, I see, I see.
But then what would this be connected to?
Unless...
Ah, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
It actually, okay, it forms the connection.
Okay.
I'm silly.
So I had the right idea.
I just was wrong.
A little bit.
This, though.
Is it the...
Oh, the book!
Wait.
What?
You can rotate after the connection.
Okay.
Oh, that's so weird.
Okay, that's what I was thinking was happening before, but it wasn't.
Okay.
Okay!
Strange.
It's not quite intuitive.
Thank you for the help, Gars.
That's about all of the ones we can work with.
This game is so vastly different than what I imagined.
Ready to pull the switch?
You know me.
Always ready.
Whoa.
Alright, let's go check out what souvenirs he brought back from the moon.
Ladies first?
Not this time.
Where do I go?
Heal?
What did you think it was going to be like?
I had no idea.
I didn't know anything about it.
Oh, hello?
Is it you?
This is the same setting as this real last accessible.
memory usually there's at least some change something isn't right these memories they feel more than having happened again they are exactly the same that's impossible the desire was transferred was it not it was if
this is indeed the same memory he'd be at the clip oh that's right my bed
Aww.
Johnny?
What a pleasant surprise.
We don't get many visitors around here.
Deja vu again.
My name is Dr. Eva Rosaline.
And this is...
What?
I'm not saying it twice.
Dr. Neil Watts.
Are you familiar with the Sigmund Agency of Life Generation?
Oh, are you two from the agency?
How convenient.
I've just been thinking of calling you.
Lily, get us some tea, please.
I'm reading the same conversation twice!
We don't...
We usually only get VTubers out here.
Freeze him, too.
Uh-oh.
Well...
Wait, here.
I'll go send you a desire signal again.
See if there's any changes.
Uh...
It transferred successfully for sure.
Any changes?
Not even a hair.
How could this be?
Even if his desire doesn't work alone, why is there no change at all?
Perhaps.
Perhaps it just needs some provoking to activate.
From his early memories?
The earliest we can get to.
Let's go.
Kind of spooky.
It's like he doesn't want to if you can't force a what if he's too dumb to become an astronaut What if he just doesn't have the brain power
Just like me I wanted to be a nurse and then I took chemistry and I give up Johnny's desire to go to the moon might need some stimulation to be brought up, huh?
Well, then Moon moon moon Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon!
What the?
This wasn't what they said was playing.
Moon, Moon.
Oh well.
Do you mind River?
What if River goes to the moon instead?
No, I like this one.
Alright, let's go then!
Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon, Moon!
I'm shaking him by his shoulders.
Moon!
Hopefully that's enough for an ignition.
I went and saw the moon movie once and I became an astronaut.
Wait.
Where is Neil?
Moon, moon, moon, moon.
Part of me, you guys?
I'm not gonna be... I'm not gonna lie.
My voice has been really hurting.
Talking so much.
I wanted to complete this in one goal, but...
I'm feeling it might be better if I make this a two-parter.
Finish next week?
I think so.
If that's okay with you guys.
I don't know why my throat is hurting so much today.
I think I've just been...
I've had to do a lot of recording and stuff lately.
So...
I haven't had so much time to actually rest my voice.
Even on the days that I'm not streaming.
what we'll do is then we will uh we will then save it for next week if that's all ready with you guys so it's kind of ending on a bit of a cliffhanger so i'm really excited to pick it back up so thank you guys meet and greets singing and recording yeah it's been kind of a lot i think maybe after the weekend the u.s idol festival i you know i was singing so much and uh I had to also sing my entire set because,
you know, just, I always, I, you know, I don't know if other people will do this, but I usually get asked that just in case, like, the internet doesn't work, that I have a backup recording that they can play.
Luckily, the internet was okay.
But so then I'm always having to do my set twice.
So, yeah, yeah.
But, yeah, we'll end it here then.
the streaming so happy oshi day i'm very happy to have encountered you and with tribe retest thank you every stream is guaranteed a smile and good time when you continue to ring that towards everyone thank you so much thank you thank you guys so seriously for all the donos and everything and the the oh sap oh wait the the the sorry the good oshi day wishes i really appreciate it
get you to laugh, maybe.
Dorko, thank you so much for the being.
Please rest your voice and feel better looking outside the moon, sure.
The moon?
The moon sure is beautiful tonight, isn't it?
I bet.
I bet it is.
Happy Yoshi Day, Vito.
I'm so glad you're my Yoshi.
Next scene, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy Yoshi Day.
Thank you.
I hope you guys all had a good day with your Yoshi.
She's...
And a horror game that detects the mic.
Oh my gosh, right?
So that I purposefully can't speak.
Take care, Minto.
Happy OCD.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for the super chats.
Thank you, guys.
I really, really appreciate it.
And all the gift and memberships and everything.
Thank you, thank you.
So I will see you when I see you next.
And next time I see you...
Well, no, sorry.
Next week!
I think...
Well, hold on, sorry, I'm checking the calendar.
Next week, I'm only streaming Monday.
So we'll finish this game on Monday.
Sound good?
Otsumito!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
It's a-o!
Bye-bye!
I really appreciate you guys so much.
Thank you!
Bye-bye!